Twitter is one of the most toxic places
I've ever been on and it's [ __ ] funny
it's just a platform for people to
[ __ ] argue with each other about
absolutely [ __ ] nothing yeah but
because of that there's so many things
that you could see that people just have
an opinion on that it just doesn't
matter it doesn't [ __ ] matter like
you could post a video about I don't
know today I took my daughter out
to buy her favorite Barbie and like did
you [ __ ] ask your daughter what
gender she is in order for her to have
that Barbie and did you ask the Barbie
what gender the Barbie is in five four
three two one Hello everybody welcome to
another episode of The Genius brain
podcast one of the stupidest podcasts
you have ever listened to we have the
stupidest of stupidest we have Nick the
ear yes everybody and then we have tank
top Patrick over here
I've been on a cycle my boys
so apparently we found that the robin
couch does sex novels Let's Go Robin she
has audio books we can tell by her voice
that she has a talent
misinformation it wasn't a sex novel it
was an erotic novel so what's the
difference though What's the diff I
don't know
I don't know setting them in Japanese
who is it for yeah who's it four who's
erotic novels for well I during the
pandemic for early 2020 when I I was
like unemployed it was before I was
working here I was like offering like
audiobook and like editing and writing
services on Fiverr wow so somebody
reached out and they were like hey it
was a woman who wrote this book and she
was like would you be comfortable like I
can send you like a piece of this I
think it was a short story actually uh
that I want an audio reading for and I
needed money hell yeah
what kind of stuff did you say she
assumed the doggy style position yeah
what did you say I it was
she remembers dude
the whole novel she hasn't memorized
it was a lot of descriptive terms like
like what are some adjectives you would
use
it also wasn't very well written because
I'm a snob like that
oh grammar sucked Harry twatter in the
store so many Obamas that's what it was
dude he's got a Sorcerer's Stone in your
pocket are you happy to see me there it
is I love it the prisoner of azkablam
let's go
Joanne's you know the material fabric
store this is years ago this is before
that like when 50 Shades of Gray first
came out I didn't even know what it was
and I saw these two old ladies they were
like 60s 70s like old they look like
grandmas like cute apple pie baking
grandmas apple pie [ __ ] say it
correctly
[ __ ] bro and uh they uh she was just
one the one of them went to the other
one was like hey guess what I was
reading last night oh the other one was
like what and then she was like 50
Shades of Gray and the other one was
like
and at the time I didn't know I looked
it up and I was like damn these old
ladies are just wet at Joanne's just
like yeah I read 50 Shades of Gray like
I was getting tied up yeah they were
ready to roll that [ __ ] was such a
[ __ ] popular book dude
I never understood it wasn't a smut
novel though was it it was just a
regular book that just had sexy ass
scenes it was it was more sex though
wasn't it Robin couch can you clarify
yeah what do you think Robin I never
read it but come on
a girl I worked with at a cafe in
college when it was like the top book
was like this is so amazing and she
loaned it to me without me asking so I
remember flipping through it like this
is garbage but it was very
um
well it was trying to be I should say
BDSM but the BDSM Community got really
upset by it because they said this is
not BDSM this is actually abuse and
there is a difference oh no standards I
had no idea oh man there's so much
Nuance in everything what was it was it
about uh an older man taking advantage
of a younger girl it was like it was
this this girl I guess she
was
couch met up with let's say the delay
for my last name
she met like this dude Christian Gray
who I guess was like rich or something
and then
he
made her sign a contract to be his sexy
yeah and then oh
it gets like I don't know and then they
start having a lot of sex I don't know
like was it notarized was the document
notarized do you know about that
all right useless [ __ ] questions you
dweeb Lord dude he says I want to get a
grasp of this book yeah I want you to
read it in your [ __ ] bubble back
today
I really don't think it's because it was
it started as
um Twilight fanfiction oh yeah that
makes sense yeah and then she Twisted it
to it and then got rich so I guess good
for them oh it's the same lady my blood
suck my dick instead Twilight's On the
Border because I remember there was a
scene in the movie where they're in a
tent and the the werewolf is like hot
naturally like body temperature wise of
course and they're in the snow and like
the girls like dying or something the
vampire is like you need to cuddle with
her to keep her warm and like this guy's
just getting cucked out like it's just
it's very borderline like cuck porn [ __ ]
but she was in high school too and he
was like 4 000 years old bro so
technically yeah
that is that is statutory we don't say
the actual word here we don't do that
Pat got to reunite with his best friend
Chris
yeah yeah
and then [ __ ] Pat and Chris went at
it again dude nah bro Chris is super
nice I love Chris sounds like he hates
him continue Chris is dope dude I love
Chris uh first time I seen him I thought
it was gonna be I didn't honestly know
what to expect because I because you
guys have been telling me that he wants
to fight me like he hates your [ __ ]
guts Afro Samurai like he's just [ __ ]
wandering the lands looking for me and
[ __ ] to get down I think you changed his
life actually I think after you kick
after you beat him in that match he left
you were the last City dude after you
kicked his [ __ ] ass
dude after you beat the [ __ ] out of
Christmas we're just trying to change it
to something else because it's exciting
for us it was really nice to see him
dude I felt good he doesn't like bonding
we're bonding chatting it up I was like
what's up dude he was like what's up and
then he was like is that your combo yeah
that was it
what's up with you fool what's up well I
didn't know how he was going to be but
then we Spartan he was very very nice
and I was like okay cool do you know
what I saw and when I saw Patrick spar
with Chris Sosa in my head I was like if
I was Chris I'd be [ __ ] heated right
now
Pat like punches him in the face like he
just tagged him over the jab Chris salsa
and then Pat goes oh I'm sorry
oh Pat always does that [ __ ] oh nice
dude Chris like oh you sorry for what
we're scaring each other what else are
you gonna do his hair started getting
curlier and [ __ ] dude his hair is nice
though now you guys had a very tame
sparring match yeah it was it was we're
just there to kick it and have a good
time yeah all right I'm just trying to
be friends with the guy ever since I've
just been like hey let's be friends this
guy's like I want to kill you
if he beat you though I probably would
have let it go yes probably yeah I don't
think so I don't think I would because
it's like okay I'm not trying to be a
professional fighter what if he knocked
you out
I mean it would have sucked but I don't
I don't think I would be like I'm gonna
fight this [ __ ] because it's
like under what circumstances like we're
not in a boxing League like when is that
ever gonna happen again you know we'll
see about that they're gonna meet in
boxingly I just want you guys to fight
again and hate each other all right yeah
it makes me so happy we like the
Christmas dope dude Chris is a really
good guy sounds like he's overcoming
David I saw David land a hard-ass crap
you left the mark first I left the mark
after yeah all right I thought that's
what we were doing leave me marks on
each other's faces you're a piece of
[ __ ] I think I don't know it was just
one one thing I overextended on that's
it that's it well the theory well not
the theory well the stories that we talk
about David kind of going hard are we
gonna talk about stories again Nick
because we didn't talk stories about you
all day all right hit him once and he
goes no there's no time there's no clock
here what are you talking about what the
[ __ ] we're just touching I know he gets
crazy and we are just touching you know
why because you guys be like you guys
are you guys are throwing hard and then
I get mad because I I have to I have to
he doesn't understand the person I
learned how to train from
[ __ ] on the sidelines so then I respond
to you guys and then you guys are like
stop yelling you know no did you not
raise my voice a little higher all of a
sudden I'm yelling here's an example
Robin does it sound like I'm yelling
oh yes it does she's like uh I'm so
sorry
yeah that's not true though is because
after you saw him and Diego were going
kind of hard like not hard but you guys
were getting it you know it was like it
was it was a nice time it was a nice one
and then afterwards I went up to because
he had my gloves I was like I took the
gloves back and I was like oh you guys
are going kind of hard and he's like
what the [ __ ] you mean we're going hard
I'm not going hard because we were that
was after the match too yeah that was
enduring what's going on what do you
mean yeah what do you mean [ __ ] hard
because that's not going hard going hard
is the difference
because I'm trying like you're from
Brooklyn New York just like me is what
I'm saying I am I'm your abuser dude
my forearm still hurts because he just
swung real quick I was like hey man
you're strong dude you know Patrick
randomly went to college with that dude
yeah oh really yeah then you watch that
gay porn class together uh I don't know
if he was in the gay porn class with me
he wasn't yeah please watch gay porns
outside of costumes
um
we did a documentary together on kissing
we were in film school so we interviewed
a bunch of people like some dude the
best part is we interviewed like a
priest we interviewed all kinds of
people about like the origins of kissing
what they think a psychologist what the
[ __ ] does a priest know huh yeah he
didn't really no [ __ ] of course you did
we like showed him a little bit at the
age of 10 disgusting the thing about
priests they love talking about kissing
his reserved for little boys love
talking about some [ __ ] that they don't
know nothing about like marriage before
a wedding that's what they've been
talking [ __ ] that's pretty true yeah I
don't know they have like a 30 minute
monologue and then they talk some [ __ ]
how could they not have sex their whole
life that's what Catholic priests at
least dude Buddhist monks they don't
they never they don't have they don't
ever indulge in anything that's like uh
like food they don't even indulge in
they don't indulge in food they don't do
none of that [ __ ] they don't eat meat
they don't have sex nothing dude I trust
a monk more than a priest though I trust
a monk too Hondo that's horrible dude
that sounds like I can't imagine because
there's some people who actually go into
becoming monks after they've already
[ __ ] that's what I'm saying okay so
they did it they got out there well
there's people who convert and they go
I'm a monk now but once you've had a
taste of [ __ ] bye you can't go
backwards there's nothing that
replicates a vagina for a heterosexual
person no there's nothing this dude's
meditating about not
every time I try to meditate I think
about sex at least 47 times and it's
like three minute meditation session
it's hard not to dude you know what I
found out
isn't it
harder bro you'd be [ __ ] I'm I'm
trying to like Riot but he's a good man
though dude when I'm at the gym with him
and there'd be some cakes walking around
this was like I ain't looking at nothing
yeah
I have to hold his head straight
I'm struggling dude you think I'm
grunting because of the weights but I'm
just like
it's hard dude I found it so because I
wanna I'm on like a caloric deficit
right
every morning what do guys get your
morning [ __ ] wood yeah right so my
morning wood I didn't snap it around for
a few days oh really really so
apparently like if you're off hey let me
tell you that Viagra base it's already
been weak as it was apparently when you
don't eat calories it gets weaker okay
that's true though your libido's
dropping that's what they say sometimes
that happens you [ __ ] know that [ __ ]
so I thought there's something wrong
because I had to go to the doctor I was
like hey yo my [ __ ] dick is not
functioning you told him that yeah and
he was like well he's like what have you
been doing I'm like well I've been
losing weight and I told him like how
much I've been losing weight he goes she
probably bump your calories up a little
bit because you know uh apparently when
you go on a caloric deficit or Diet like
it [ __ ] with your like libido issue how
how many how many calories well I think
it's because I started upping up my
workouts and I didn't change not
recovering enough huh yeah so that's why
I had that repeat thing I had two big
ass burritos
hell yeah dude yeah but I didn't know
that [ __ ] dude nobody told me this makes
a lot Nick but you know the thing about
like David anytime he does something he
always gets like like the disclaimers on
like medicines that like uh allergy
medicine like you always get the worst
effects like just like that the fact
that you I'm it's pretty rare when
someone starts dieting and then their
dick don't work or like that is kind of
rare I feel like do you have to like
seriously be dieting like for a chronic
amount of time but for you it's just a
couple of weeks of just going hard in
the paint and then my dick don't work
dude just two weeks per day I had a
burrito then my dick got hard it was
crazy of my life I literally started
eating the burrito and my dick
it's the one I needed
check it out so we're doing something
different all right all right so on my
on my uh free time when I was
specifically had covered for like seven
days all I did was peruse the internet
and what I found out is that I really
[ __ ] like Twitter really Twitter is
one of the most toxic places I've ever
been on and it's [ __ ] funny it's just
a platform for people to [ __ ] argue
with each other about absolutely [ __ ]
nothing yeah but because of that there's
so many things that you could see that
people just have an opinion on that it
just doesn't matter it doesn't [ __ ]
matter like you could post a video about
I don't know today I took my daughter
out
to buy her favorite Barbie and like did
you [ __ ] ask your daughter what
gender she is in order for her to have
that Barbie and did you ask the Barbie
what gender the Barbie is yeah it could
just be a male with long and I'm I [ __ ]
you [ __ ] not these are the arguments
that are happening sure some people
think it's stupid some people agree and
they just [ __ ] fight each other I
think it's just for sport so that's why
we have a fun segment where we just go
through Twitter [ __ ] it's the best Robin
couch right nothing first one whoa
that's already fire dude the voicemail
so it was great so we want the person
who looks the most white to uh read that
voicemail please yeah what is the title
of the voicemail it's okay
uh toxic yeah nutty uh-huh and then
there's uh an N word
there's always some [ __ ] on Twitter
about somebody posting or blasting
somebody's ex right and this one was
[ __ ] crazy so this girl she goes
y'all I can't believe my ex at this
point y'all need to listen to this I
can't make this up oh my God and this is
a voicemail that this toxic toxic toxic
toxic I'm getting nervous because of the
third word
say it David say it
I feel like that's like a quirky word
button so we could hear this Robin I
wanna I'm interested
uh audio might not come through because
I'm really good at my job
I'm just gonna have to read it yeah you
have to smut novels word for words
I can't read that though um oh I could
play here right here
okay we'll just we'll just overlay it
after
one two three like his it's like his
voicemail yeah yeah is this to you dude
I do not refer myself to as the N word
only to my black friends one two three
yo yo yo you [ __ ] play with me to
[ __ ] work
[ __ ] prank that's the [ __ ] phone
that's a [ __ ] is wrong with you stop
[ __ ] playing answer the phone now
stop playing stop playing dude that's
the [ __ ] phone you know you know [ __ ]
it [ __ ] it
I'm gonna play a song for you that I
made you don't want to answer before I'm
gonna play something for you going to
[ __ ] feel what I feel [ __ ] I feel
what I feel [ __ ]
this doesn't sound that crazy yet
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh it's his original track
sounds like Usher
dad
you have to tell me a [ __ ] again I don't
believe you
tell me again
kind of a banger dude it does not not
enough Justice on the voicemail system
your [ __ ] best friends you call them
[ __ ] the rap stay away from them
laughs
one more time
[Music]
you know I'm [ __ ] crazy you go crazy
at least he said it
oh
that's vibing right now too
this is actually this song is good dude
let me tell you something
[Music]
call me back please this is don't sound
like crazy
the best part about [ __ ] Twitter is
never the post is always the [ __ ]
comments of course always remember Jerry
Springer when they would ask questions
at the end that was always the best part
so this is the one that's very
interesting this is like this is a take
from a dude y'all don't block your exes
because you love the attention and then
come on here and call them toxic when
they start acting out block delete don't
engage and report them to the police if
they get violent stalk you so basically
there's like a a little thing that's
going on here where people well that's
the thing too like I don't think a lot
of people know is that when somebody is
stalking you you don't delete [ __ ] you
don't block their [ __ ] number because
you don't know when they're gonna come
after you you don't know when what
they're going to do or what their next
move is so you actually need this for
evidence so you do not block people but
a lot of people don't [ __ ] know that
so like when you have somebody who's
like I only know this because I had a
friend who had a stalker you need to
pile a lot of evidence specifically as a
girl they just technically just don't
believe either [ __ ] yeah yeah so when
you have like somebody who goes after
you like this you have to record [ __ ]
everything do not block terrible and
have a paper trail of this [ __ ]
and all those tracks that he did well
you've only had one lady your whole life
because you're a little [ __ ] what would
you know dude I don't know anything
about dating that's why it's like I'm
like yeah all right whatever you guys
need to do what made you just look at
Tiff and be like that's the one it just
worked out everything just like
well-defense
don't get these dots in my head let's
overlay the music over there don't
listen to your friends they [ __ ]
tip a voicemail like this and she's you
love me you guys never broke up once not
I remember there was like early when we
were like what'd you do 19. what did you
do why she's very sweet
um I don't I wish I remembered it was it
was something it was some stupid [ __ ]
because like what do you argue about
when you're [ __ ] 19 you know but it
was like it was probably like two three
years in that we were dating and then
she was like I want to take a break or
some [ __ ] I remember saying like if we
take a break we might as well just break
up oh yes
what is the use of a break and at that
time on my head to try some new [ __ ]
[ __ ] I missed the memo you did no but uh
at the time I just was like we might as
well just break up because there's no
point in us going on a break it's either
we figure this [ __ ] out talk it out or
whatever or sometimes when you're young
you need some space to think without
somebody breathing down their [ __ ]
neck no 100 and space is good that's
that's actually what I should have done
really is just be like all right let's
take a [ __ ] and then you force her to
be with you yeah exactly and we've been
together ever since ever since my boy
yeah but I gave her I wasn't an
ultimatum at the time I just in my head
it was literally like you gave it the
one point but what are the rules of a
break though that's I don't know you
have to you have to set that from the
jump yeah
sometimes what kind of breaker we take
are we taking like a word together but
we just need space break are we taking
like a free-for-all hey have you been on
a break yeah I've been on a break I know
what you I know
it didn't really thank God getting your
[ __ ] condoms
so he gets the condom all the way to the
end so you just have to search for it in
there
I got a pack of sugar I was waiting for
this like a package
dude it didn't work out when I went on a
break it didn't work out it was just
like it was like a breakup how much
vagina did you smash in between the
break because I know that's why you guys
broke up these thoughts in my head
I miss you big
bro I've had girls actually in in high
school we're like middle school high
school whatever you know those early
breakups and they would uh or breaks or
break up whatever the [ __ ] it was and
I've had them call and leave like
voicemails of just songs did you ever
did you guys ever get that
they left you songs so like I would like
we originally we'd have a fight no we'd
have a fight and then like I'd I
wouldn't pick up the call it's like
Jasmine's calling and I didn't pick up
and the voicemail I'd listen to it later
it's like if you had one wish
and it would be like a minute of the
song and then click you guys never had
that never mind used to do that to break
up with a guy get the [ __ ] out of here
she would like
like his girlfriend whoa
cartoon dude I didn't say she was a good
person okay
once they were still friends
smaller though to break up with a via
song yeah with a note that's done that
[ __ ]
straight forward like that because my
dumb ass would be like I've never even
gotten dumped before you even know how
that feels it's dumped bro who dumped
you oh that's right you did get dumb
[ __ ] losers
it was this girl that I used to talk to
in high school and we were like kind of
dating or some [ __ ] and I think it was
like the first time I ever got in a
relationship like that or like I like
the girl that liked me back you know and
uh yeah that was awesome yeah
now that that's when you go what a
[ __ ] loser that's cool no that's cool
if you do that thing where you had the
[ __ ] little trap thing
forever
yeah yes you like me yes or yeah and she
already filled it in it says hell no
she's like [ __ ] you nah but uh I think I
just got too [ __ ] I just didn't know
how to be in a relationship or how to
like be with a girl like that so I
learned real quick that I scared her off
and she was like all right then and then
she was like yeah we shouldn't we
shouldn't talk anymore and then cut to
me in the shower like ah
oh yeah dude I was heartbroken dude in
middle school I remember a [ __ ] loser
dude like I didn't know like I was so
nervous to talk to girls or whatever and
I liked this girl and I just told her I
was I told her friends I like to write
and they got the message to her and then
I heard she liked me back and then I was
like oh [ __ ] like this girl likes me
back I don't know what I'm supposed to
do we like ended up talking and we're
like hey let's be boyfriend and
girlfriend and like after that the
pressure the title of being boyfriend
and girlfriend I didn't know what to do
at all with it and I would get so
nervous that I just avoided her for like
two weeks
this podcast is brought to you by
athletic greens my friends I do not
start my day without my athletic green
so what is athletic green specifically a
g one it's delicious and guess what when
you drink it you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals Whole Food
Source ingredients probiotics and
adaptogens to help start your day right
we're talking about energy recovery
focus and aging put all that CIS dust
stuff into your gut health your nervous
system your immune system and it helps
all those things why do I personally
consume it my friends because it helps
me start my day like I already told you
it makes me feel great and I don't start
my day without it it costs you less than
three dollars a day and you're investing
in your health and my friend's health is
wealth I don't ever skimp on my health
anymore I used to do that when I was
younger and I messed up and now I'm
trying to get my life back and I started
with my ag1 baby to make it easy
athletic range is going to give you a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamins D and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com geniusbrain again
that is athleticgreens.com geniusbrain
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
Insurance
like she used to hang out in the
cafeteria and I would just walk around
like I wouldn't because I didn't know
what I was supposed to do
oh [ __ ]
look I literally would see her like if
we were walking down a hot steer I'd
turn around and like go the other way
I'd be like nah
[Laughter]
that likes this Christ three weeks later
I can ruin her lifestyle no she broke up
with me and I was sorry
officially she called me and was like
Hey we got to break up because you're
being [ __ ] weird
because I haven't seen you since and I
don't know where you're at and you
actively avoid me we make eye contact
and you turn around and leave uh and I
was so happy I was like I was like I
couldn't I was so relieved I was like I
just don't have to do that anymore whoa
yeah what do you think that is like it
was just the pressure of not knowing
what to do and I'm missing up or
something 11 or 12. what did you think
that you had to do I that's the thing is
I didn't know and then and I felt like I
was supposed I didn't know at all where
to start doing anything boyfriend
girlfriend related and then there was
the pressure of everyone knew you were
in a relationship so everyone was like
watch every time you're around each
other people are like like yeah because
they're kids you know and I was like
[ __ ] all I don't know I was like [ __ ]
this dude I just avoided everything at
all just ran away how [ __ ] confusing
is that for that little girl she's like
I like you I like you too all right
peace [ __ ] yeah I got issues then you
just bounce we're together now
that's my like my little trauma you know
I don't I don't know what the [ __ ] that
was
yeah well it was on her through me
probably dude if I had one wish that was
actually my my first song with My First
Girlfriend Chris yeah that was our song
dude I would watch the music video of
him in the rain we could be the best and
I would like be in Hong Kong homes what
the [ __ ] that home class whatever when
you would read and go to school today
15 minutes and I would like listen to it
on my iPod and be like [ __ ] I love my
girlfriend so much
I'm not gonna make the same mistakes
when I was 11 okay I'm not that guy
anymore you were always embarrassing for
you remember like in elementary school
where uh every Valentine's Day the girls
would give guys Valentine's cards right
I would always feel bad for the kid that
because even I at least got one but
there was always be like one or two kids
that never got any that [ __ ] used to
hurt me to watch I thought they had to
give it to all the kids after a while so
I remember when I was at third or fourth
grade I can't remember but
um they kind of made it a rule in school
that if you do get that you have to give
it to every guy yeah
everyone I remember a kid who didn't get
any cars and even I got one right and
let me tell you something I was shocked
when I got one I was like my cup my work
you saved me I'm not gonna be like that
[ __ ] loser but what kind of candy was
in it huh it was like the uh shitty one
that the [ __ ] the bracelet the
bracelets the shitty bracelet candy the
smarties or whatever that you bite them
all that you buy it you eat them I kind
of like them you can launch that people
they're kind of gross though to be like
melting on your wrist I got one from
this girl and then I got another one
from another girl who's just a friend
right sure because we lived on the same
block or whatever but it was very nice
to have now I remember I used to get
nervous like I can't be that [ __ ]
loser that doesn't get any [ __ ] candy
somebody and I got two most people on
average got like six or seven yeah yeah
but at least I wasn't a [ __ ] loser
like that one other Asian kid oh man but
I remember poor guy and not getting one
and I remember him crying yeah that [ __ ]
made me feel so bad rejection and I went
over to him like everyone knows it
is standing right in front of his face
but you know you don't really think
about like how much that hurts the
little kids feelings right I was glad
that I I got my candy and then after you
have to everybody every time you gave a
gift or the the Valentine's card you had
to give one to everybody but the girls
had a workaround the person that they
liked they would give them a special
card right so it'd be a little different
because the other ones were super
[ __ ] generic yeah so either way you
knew that you were a loser but at least
you got some [ __ ] candy you got some
candy bro I hope that kid is buffed as
[ __ ] now I hope that kid crush is
killing it you don't have to be the
Unabomber
oh there you go should have should have
got a valentine gram then let's go to
the next one what else we got Twitter
baby that song was good by the way
that's that's what I'm yeah that was the
the star there yeah that was that's the
moral of that story
I thought I was expecting it to be a
little darker we got another one it's
called Uh Native American white lady why
did oh this this is not water activity
who's gone wild yeah yeah the hot dog
water activities Native American Student
Records math teachers follow this person
okay well guess what I'll tell you guys
see it on the culture this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
it this is the most wildest [ __ ] you've
I've ever [ __ ] seen right so what
you're about to witness is a lady if you
guys are just listening to this is a
teacher kind of pretending to be like a
cartoon Native American in class
teaching a class I think I've seen this
why do people do this I don't know it's
half your people
ah
so far
is that the thing from geometry dude
from calculus
no
this is a [ __ ] teacher
she's getting laughed she's getting
laughed she's getting laughs yeah she's
killing right now bro
[Music]
wow she's going for it there wasn't a
video they could have watched this is
the most uncomfortable [ __ ] thing
I've ever seen she took this upon
herself to do a live performance for the
class yes
and I get all of my friends this is
upsetting well this is in Riverside
California dude homie right here
like what's crazy is that you could just
easily not do this
are you just easily is so unnecessary
like why are you doing that and what are
we learning here are we learning
anything from this woman you know why
this [ __ ] cracked me up that's she gave
a great performance this is two minutes
long by the way I had to think about
this it's like she first did the joke
originally nobody laughed and she had to
go louder so she could get a laugh you
know what she did she did the Kramer
dude that's exactly what she did the
Kramer yeah
she could double down she went all the
way in
Houston like she was losing the room so
she [ __ ] doubled down she stood on
the desk that's because once the laugh
went away she goes oh people aren't
laughing I have to go higher I have to
do more and so she kept on trying to get
more laughs it's like dude it's not
working let the set go
I want to know I want to know why this
happened I want to know like the days
did she did she say hey on Thursday I'm
gonna do a performance for you guys did
they just come in and she just performed
it'd be hilarious if she has a Native
American so math I think it's a math
class right what the [ __ ] does that [ __ ]
have to do with a math class yeah it
says math on there oh [ __ ] she's talking
about [ __ ] words this [ __ ] have to do
walrus on the wall you know I I'm not a
big fan of like you know telling people
they should lose their job but she
should lose her job for that you think
so that's crazy bro because it's not
it's not even she's being a good teacher
she's not even good at teaching math
that's what I was gonna say I don't
think she should lose her job
necessarily for that I think it should
be because these [ __ ] are
supposed to be learning math
a two minute performance that's not any
good and has no context to the actual
[ __ ] material dude one of my in high
school this was a pretty [ __ ] crazy
thing uh there was two things that
happened there was one with my brother
that happened in his class uh and then
one within my class so you guys remember
a JROTC yeah sounds familiar the ROTC
thing where they would do the military
RTC and they would do like the flag the
flag torahland they'd walk around with
the [ __ ] guns and all that [ __ ] oh
yeah they learn how to fold Flags
American flags like color guard for
dudes right yeah yeah I don't even know
what color guards are but that [ __ ]
sounds that's when they would twirl
flies
there it is
why I said cool yeah right it wasn't
cool so can we can we ask what was your
motivation at the time for doing Color
Guard
um my my sister was already in it she
was two years older than me and then all
of my friends were deciding to audition
and I kind of just auditioned for shits
and gigs and turned out I was halfway
decent holy [ __ ] um I only did it for
two years though because it was the
coaches were dicks so you know what we
do we're in trouble we [ __ ] throw a
bow staff to Robin and see everybody see
what happens dude what's the difference
between cheerleading and color guard
um cheer cheerleaders cheer at football
game yeah you [ __ ] idiots
yeah dude sorry guys go to all the games
in the pom-poms
what are pom-poms next [ __ ] question
okay okay they go to the games but what
do color guards do color guard
um like during field season
go out with them
with them spin Flags rifles and Sabers
in the formations that the marching band
does while they play their music on the
field
ROTC [ __ ] I told you yeah you can do
color guard as well no they can't
inclusive they want [ __ ] here we go but
it was like this dude at JROTC right
there was this crazy [ __ ] Scandal
that happened in my school so I
specifically remember this young Asian
girl and she was like dined up with all
this [ __ ] badgery you know what do
you call this stuff like cheese yeah
purple heart and all that yeah all this
other stuff like War [ __ ] right yeah
yeah but I'm like how the [ __ ] you 14
[ __ ] like how you got all this [ __ ] for
him yeah
she keeps on getting promoted and all
this other stuff right and I'm not I'm
not just making this up on the spot
people were questioning this [ __ ] so
there was this uh a park next to my
house right kind of a little ghetto Park
well lo and behold in the wee bits of
the morning we see a SUV where the
[ __ ] glass is fogged up Titanic Style
no way so one of the I don't know what
they're called the Grand Master what is
that that's some KKK [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
same system the grand wizard he was I
got Dragon apparently he was smashing
those little moon cakes
I don't
look it was pretty [ __ ] nuts dude and
I felt so bad because it was a dude in
my Japanese class who really liked this
girl and then when he found out I
remember class he started bawling and
crying man
okay no the news broke the news to him
he was all the [ __ ] news yeah but
don't cry over that huh
yeah like you just liked her they
weren't even in a relationship right
yeah she didn't even know you existed
yeah I felt where do you think you got
that purple heart from huh you gotta be
wounded in battle to get that metal if
she was wounded come on dude all right
dude enough of the Moon everybody called
her moon cakes dude I I lied I just made
that up
oh no Robbie can we fact check that
please what a [ __ ] rapper dude
in my brother's ear this this happened
and my brother's uh three or four years
older than me
there was a a teacher that was like
trying to pick up on young high school
students right and guess how they found
him or they got him so at the time the
the sheriff's department was doing like
undercover [ __ ]
she was uh going online so the sheriff's
I believe the sheriff's daughter was
also a deputy and then they would set up
these guys where she would pretend to be
a young girl and so it was it was a
teacher from my high school
uh but he's not there now because by the
time I got to high school he wasn't
there but in my brother's here he did
the whole thing where they they [ __ ]
uh 2020 what do you call that [ __ ]
ancestry [ __ ] no no the stuff with that
guy Chris hansoned him oh that Chris
hansened him
and when they were there it was the
deputy and the sheriff and they [ __ ]
arrested him because he was trying to
you know basically have he was talking
to a federal agent dude on the chat on
the team chat how [ __ ] crazy is that
[ __ ] bro that could happen to one of our
kids one day dude I feel like correct me
if I'm wrong but it seems like if you're
a teacher at a high school and you're
trying to get underage you know moon
cakes as you said Oh They'll say that
bro that's disgusting I'm just saying I
feel like it's a guarantee that like
you're gonna get got bro yeah you're
playing a risky game like it's like it's
like 85 you're gonna get kids like high
school gossip think about how much
gossip like you can't be a student that
like even like the guys that end up
ratting on the the female teachers it's
like just keep that [ __ ] to yourself
yeah bro you know dude
everybody I feel like my school was so
[ __ ] up
shut your [ __ ] mouth okay God damn it
there was a I still keep in contact with
this uh with this teacher too but there
was somebody in my class that had a
gigantic crush on one of our teachers I
thought you're gonna say something else
[ __ ] no but she had a huge and then he
felt so uncomfortable around her because
she wanted to be like uh his after
school assistant yeah she was really
academic very nice and then you gotta go
somewhere else no sorry the only reason
why I knew this is because uh she was
telling people that she had a crush on
somebody right because she was within
our Circle
um like on the periphery right and so
what I just asked I was like who do you
have a crush on it she was being really
shy about it and then she said the
teacher's name and I thought it was a
[ __ ] joke and she legit had a crush
on the [ __ ] teacher that should be
happening so me listen I ain't no snitch
but that teacher was my boy like he
looked after me so I had to give him a
heads up I was like hey just to let you
know like I gotta let you know this
because if you want some yeah yeah yeah
she's ready
and I'm saying that she wants it
but till this day to this damn day this
little thanks me for it because he felt
something very weird about her that is
weird exactly you know he's a good guy
when we were kids we don't also realize
that these people who are teachers but
actually not that much older than us
yeah he was maybe six years older than
me at the time because we were eight I
was 18. so he was only 24. yeah so when
he when he found that out and then she
was all heartbrokers like bro but you
could have got this fool in jail over
some crazy [ __ ] that you were gonna do
yeah you can I love that t-shirt because
he was probably the only reason why I
graduated high school wow yeah say his
name I cannot I refuse to give out
personal detail like that but just to
let you know your boys are snitch damn I
bit a snitch don't tell me nothing no
that's cool though in that situation
that's good that's awesome because I
mean yeah it's like dude I I would want
to know too because it's weird it's like
I don't want to be even and remotely
close to that [ __ ] I don't know how that
[ __ ] happens though man like there
are there are plenty of men out there
why why this why this person well he was
a good looking dude though you're in
high school you know like and then also
I feel like anyone one older than you in
high school you're like oh you think
there's like more there's just something
cool about it you know because you're on
the cusp of being an adult so I think
because you know what the most you know
what the most annoying thing that you
remember I used to hear from a lot of
like young girls was whenever they dated
somebody that was way above their age
they would go I'm really mature for my
age yeah dude I like yourself you're not
mature for your age he likes young [ __ ]
you need to run yeah it is very [ __ ]
weird a rapper
he's a Rapier here's a Rapier those guys
are always a little funky dude all those
guys that would always I remember there
was a couple guys that we went to high
school with who like graduated and they
would come back and I think I was like a
junior at the time they graduated and
they would start dating like the
sophomores no you know and at the time I
was like wow no you are already out my
boy like you already there's so much
last day of high school you just never
come back you don't come back you don't
go Epic no High School reunions no you
don't go to the high school reunion
had zero zero school spirit and and for
some reason the year that we talked our
last day our last rally when they were
like you guys are going to graduate
there was a dude that just screamed out
he goes [ __ ] this this shit's [ __ ]
good and then everybody just cracked the
[ __ ] up and left we didn't give a [ __ ]
we wanted to leave and just go do our
own thing yeah that school's lame so
that guy that always comes back to high
school to kick it with his friends it's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing dude
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah that's
uncomfortable he's over here smoking
with the teachers I know dude there's
like one dude that would uh and at the
time I think we were like sophomores but
he was like this he was like a star
basketball player big tall like six foot
black dude he was like really cool and
he would always come up and like try to
kick it with us and we'd always be like
oh cool whatever turned out he drugged
one of our homies wow and was like
trying to [ __ ] him dude a guy oh god
bang his butt get the [ __ ] out of the
homie woke up and was like like he was
sore he no he wasn't sort like I think
he was able to get out of that situation
but he had like uh like some something
similar to like food poisoning where he
just was like [ __ ] up so for the next
like a week he couldn't go back to
school where the [ __ ] is that guy now he
bro he I remember he was everywhere he
was trying to [ __ ] me too dude yeah
that's what I'm saying bro like and your
boy at that time please don't coin that
terms after your moon cakes I have my
moon cakes he liked what I was cooking
with you know what how does this guy
just even think about getting drugs and
just raping people like that it's just
people there's some people
will be on these streets probably Cosby
oh my god dude yeah all right really do
you remember that party where that that
kid passed away the kid from the south
pass it was at that party and that guy
got drugged by that dude yeah and it was
somebody you know what was going on at
that party that [ __ ] was wild that party
someone's dying somebody she was wild
I was there I went to high school with
the girl whose house it was and the guys
who threw the party those guys were high
school guys what were you doing there
you [ __ ] leaving early bro because
you know what I bumped into that big
tall black dude that was trying to [ __ ]
all of us I bumped into him and I was
like yeah your boy's out dude and I left
I left yeah that's [ __ ] nuts man
this has nothing to do with this but you
know because I grew up in a very
religious household uh there was a buddy
of mine who was a pastor's kid and I
think he's a pastor now but there was
another dude that he uh they were two
best friends one guy they were both like
from Chris so they kind of had like
create access or whatever but you know
use like sleep over at your friend's
house and whatever whatnot like if you
guys want to go kick at the mall the
next day like just come out crash in my
spot and we'll go tomorrow so this book
came back to church one day super
traumatized and he's like hyper
Christian so it's super homophobic
I love that preface yes super homophobic
right like I remember like Korean people
they play Touch butt a lot like we'd be
doing like gay ass jokes it's just yeah
we're very comfortable with that sexual
and be grabbing ass whatever whatnot he
was never down with that [ __ ] and so it
turns out that his best friend at the
time hilarious guy by the way not on
purpose because he couldn't pronounce
anything in English so I used to always
make fun of him but he uh
he he opened up to him that he was gay
while he was sleeping over to the guy
who was the most homophobic dude in the
church so he told me that they were
fossils they were sleeping in the same
bed
right oh and the guy is they're laying
next to each other he turns to him he
goes hey I'm going to tell you something
so like uh I'm a gay
and the full pretended like he was still
asleep that's a good move he said he was
so scared like as if he was going to
like sexually assault him he said he was
so scared he just pretended like he was
asleep but he didn't know whether he
should turn this way to give him his ass
or turn this way to you see his face
because he was afraid he was gonna kiss
him I was like I don't think that's how
it [ __ ] works guys yeah you guys are
friends yeah so he opens up to him and
he made it so [ __ ] awkward that guy
we never saw him since oh I bet wow he
just up and he left I haven't seen him
since then
but we have to contact them I don't know
what he's doing I bet you live in the
gay ass life though at that time of his
life
enjoying life hey it's okay if you would
have opened up to me I would have kissed
you on the [ __ ] mouth
you're inclusive dog I've been inclusive
my dad's so [ __ ] funny because he's a
pastor being inclusive my dad as a
pastor you know uh I forgot what the
prop number was but it was for
legalizing gay marriage in California
but people would come over to our house
and they would put the prop to say like
no on Prop 8 right that was the one
where you don't want people to have gay
marriage yeah yeah right it was
confusing so somebody came up and it's
like hey this is for Gabe like we don't
want gay marriage it's against you know
God or whatever and my dad being a
pastor he's like all right go ahead put
it on and somebody came the next day and
they said yes I'm Prop 8 and they're
like hey we want people to you know get
marriage because people are people when
you have a family like okay and so my
dad had a yes
and people would walk by like
that's how you do
my dad just didn't understand why people
were so confused that's so funny dude
shout outs to my pop stupid dude been
inclusive baby he taught you he bowed it
he bowed it he about that life he never
cared he was just like I believe this
whole thing about life goes I don't care
that's the thing is why would the [ __ ]
would anyone care I don't you know I
think that's the best way to that's like
the best middle ground of like all this
political [ __ ] you just go because at
the end of the day you don't really give
a [ __ ] about a lot of these [ __ ]
things don't give a [ __ ] yeah if you're
waking up every day and you're wondering
what [ __ ] goes somewhere where vagina
goes what you're a [ __ ] loser dude
yeah dude I don't care yeah just bring
it over here dude bring it over here
bring all the dicks over here let's go
next moon cakes he's ready
that wraps up this episode
when you refer to other Asian people
please don't call the moon cakes moon
cakes but if you do please credit the
sources
I think you're definitely the very first
person to ever coin that term and talk
about someone's room yeah
it sounds like a treat too you know what
I mean it is depending on who you talk
to that's true it is kind of a treat
well you guys could find Nick Nick of
the ear and you can find
patrick.t.riley
Instagram DM them all of your moon cakes
immediately they want to see it let's go
genius bring every Sundays at 12 p.m
we'll see you all next time peace
foreign
[Music]